d'un côté du ring Rima Ayadi championne
continental des poils légers qui
remettait sa ceinture en jeu ce soir et
de l'autre l'Ukrainienne Olena
Medvedenko championne d'Europe des poids
léger
un combat dominé par la pissia Khazri
mahayadi qui se termine par une victoire
pleine de panache globalement ça s'est
bien passé j'ai senti que j'étais
au-dessus techniquement et physiquement
comme mon adversaire qui est championne
d'Europe donc c'est déjà top je suis
fier de moi franchement je suis fier de
la prestation après j'ai vu qu'il y
avait aussi des choses à corriger Rima
Ayadi se classe dans les cinq premières
mondiales WBA grâce à sa victoire elle
vise maintenant les championnats
d'Europe avant de pouvoir atteindre un
jour un titre mondial au programme de ce
gala 5 combats amateurs 5 combats
professionnels et deux ceintures en jeu
le public était d'ailleurs au
rendez-vous pour soutenir les boxeurs
Ambroise Chris
on vient voir tout le monde quand même à
l'égalité et on les soutient on est
derrière on espère qu'on faire un bon
combat mais après normalement ça
m'étonnerait pas qu'il fasse un bon
combat ils ont ils ont le talent pourri
il y a pas il y a pas il y a pas de
raison qui réussissent pas on espère
passer une bonne soirée voir beaucoup de
spectacles on vient de loin pour donner
la force
allez allez on est ensemble Ali
organisées par le club bam l'héritage un
club fer de lance des Yvelines
et c'est clair que aujourd'hui c'est une
fierté en tant que président et en tant
que dirigeant du club je suis fier de
mon équipe je suis fier de mes athlètes
je suis fier de mes frangins parce que
c'est aussi difficile à faire ce genre
de plateau le club Illinois lance un
appel pour trouver des partenaires et
pouvoir renouveler ses soirées
prochainement